[Musique]
verbal est adoptée sous les réserves
d'usagé monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité du
gouvernement je vous rappelle que la
séance est retransmise en direct sur
public sénat sur le site internet du
sénat et sur facebook au nom du bureau
du sénat
j'appelle chacun de vous mes chers
collègues a observé au cours de nos
échanges
l'une des valeurs essentielles du sénat
le respect qu'il s'agisse du respect des
uns et des autres ou de celui des temps
de trappes de travail j'allais dire
temps de parole la parole est à monsieur
thani mohamed soly pour le groupe la
république en marche pour deux minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
mardi dernier deux surveillants ont été
grièvement blessés par un détenu et sa
compagne dans une unité de vie familiale
de la maison centrale de condé sur
sarthe
nos pensées vont d'abord vers ces hommes
et vers leurs familles ils ont vécu dans
leur chair cette attaque que vous avez
vous même qualifié madame la garde des
sceaux d' attaque terroriste
il s'agit bien de cela au dollar comme
en témoignent les mouvements devant
certains établissements
hier et ce matin l'émotion est vive
parmi les personnels pénitentiaires et
les bien sûr légitime à ces femmes et à
ces hommes qui derrière les murs de nos
prisons exercent au quotidien un métier
difficile mais connue de nos concitoyens
est surtout essentiel pour la sécurité
de notre pays je voudrais exprimer la
gratitude et le respect de la
représentation nationale depuis 18 mois
le gouvernement a beaucoup agi pour les
personnels pénitentiaires
cette ambition se manifeste notamment
dans le projet de loi de programmation
et de réformes pour la justice que vous
avez défendu devant le parlement depuis
l'automne et qui porte à la fois des
moyens pour l'administration
pénitentiaire sur les quatre années à
venir une réforme du sens et de
l'efficacité des peines et des mesures
qui doivent permettre de renforcer la
sécurité des personnels de surveillance
et des établissements madame la ministre
au-delà de cet effort budgétaire qui est
nécessaire et de ces mesures
vous pouvez pouvez vous nous dire ce qui
a déjà été entrepris et surtout ce que
vous comptez faire pour améliorer encore
la sécurité de nos prisons merci la
parole est à mme adami grève et louvain
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
madame la présidente des amis sénatrice
monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
président ce wali il ya 48 heures je me
suis effectivement rendu au chevet des
deux agents qui ont été gravement
blessées lors de l'attaqué terroriste
qui a eu lieu à condé sur sarthe
je tiens à témoigner devant vous de leur
professionnalisme et du courage face à
une attaque
d'une rare violence nous devons leur
rendre hommage ainsi qu'aux forces de
sécurité qui ont mis fin à cette attaque
une enquête judiciaire est en cours et
de mon côté j'ai saisi l'inspection
générale de la justice pour analyser les
conditions dans lesquelles cette attaque
a pu intervenir
condé sur sarthe est en effet un
établissement sécuritaire avec un
quartier de prise en charge de la
radicalisation ouverte depuis septembre
dernier les tables l'établissement peut
s'appuyer sur des personnels dont la
compétence est unanimement reconnue
c'est pour cela qu'il nous faut mieux
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
nous devons en effet je crois nous poser
des questions les procédures de fouilles
des visiteurs en particulier dans ces
établissements sécuritaires son talent
adapter les moyens techniques pour la
détection d'objets métalliques
peuvent-ils être amélioré et renforcé
les éléments de dangerosité des détenus
sont ils bien prises en compte pour
assurer leur affectation notamment dans
le cadre de l'accès aux unités de vie
familiale depuis 18 mois vous l'avez
rappelé notre gouvernement a agi pour
renforcer la protection des personnels
de surveillance
nous avons en effet décidé de recruter
1100 personnel de surveillance
supplémentaires
nous avons renforcé les effectifs du
renseignement pénitentiaire nous avons
amélioré les équipements de sécurité des
surveillants pénitentiaires une
réorganisation de la sécurité
pénitentiaire de l'administration
centrale sera présenté dès la semaine
prochaine
soyez assurés que c'est une action
déterminée que nous conduisons en lien
avec les organisations syndicales que je
recevrai très prochainement à ce sujet
bien sûr j'entends les impatiences je
les comprends mais soyez sûrs que la
résolution du gouvernement est
absolument sans faille
parce que la sécurité de nos
établissements et nos personnels est une
condition qui n'est pas négociable et
nous y travaillons activement
monsieur morel sur les listes souhaitez
vous remercie la parole est à madame
maryse carrère pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation
mardi dernier le quotidien le quotidien
sud-ouest titré aides européennes pour
le secteur rural la france va-t-elle
perdre ses millions ces interrogations
cette interrogation fait suite au
constat de sous-consommation du fonds
leader se former depuis 1991 un
véritable moteur de développement
il apporte un soutien à l'innovation à
la mise en réseau et à la coopération
sur nos territoires ruraux
nous savons tous combien la constitution
d'un dossier pour demander des fonds
leader peut être fastidieuse mais nous
savons aussi combien le versement
s'apparente à un véritable parcours du
combattant
en effet sur l'enveloppé initiale de 700
millions seuls 4 % auraient été versés
vous reconnaîtrez monsieur le ministre
qui nous faut mieux faire mieux faire
parce qu'à l'heure où l'on reproche trop
souvent à l'europe à l'europe d'être
éloigné de nos citoyens le programme
leader est un axe fort de son action au
bénéfice de nos territoires ruraux mieux
faire parce que derrière ces aides non
versées ce sont des artisans des
commerçants des acteurs sociaux et
culturels culturel et de nombreuses
communes qui sont fragilisés si des
progrès ont été récemment effectués par
l'état et qu'il arrive renforcer sa
mobilisation dans l'assistance des
régions qui ont joint leurs appels
récupérer l'instruction des dossiers
quasiment du jour au lendemain
des doutes subsistent alors que le
président de lider france parle de crash
généralisée du programme que de trop
nombreux projets sont à l'arrêt
pouvez-nous monsieur le ministre nous
rassurer sur le versement des fonds
prévus pour la période 2014 2020 avant
le terme de celle-ci et enfin à l'heure
de la renégociation du cadre financier
pluriannuel 2021 et 2027
pouvez-nous nous rassurer sur le
maintien de l' enveloppe actuellement
octroyés dans le cadre du dispositif
dispositif leader je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur didier guillot
mines
istres de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices madame la sénatrice je ne
vais absolument pas vous rassurer parce
que la situation n'est pas rassurante
vous parlez des fonds leader et vous
savez très bien comment les choses se
passent le programme leader c'est 700
millions d'euros attribuée à la france
pour que les fonds puissent être
attribués ils doivent passer par les
groupes d'action locaux légal ces
groupes d'action locaux sont en relation
avec les collectivités locales et
notamment les intercommunalités
intercommunautés elle même qui entrent
en relation avec les régions or
aujourd'hui comme c'était le cas déjà
avant très peu de dossiers tous les
dossiers ont été présentés mais très peu
les dossiers santa purée est donc grand
pu être payés et effectivement la france
c'est absolument un drame va perdre
plusieurs millions voire plusieurs
centaines de millions liées à l'europe
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas acceptable
c'est la raison pour laquelle il reste
encore quelques temps pour faire
accélérer ses dossiers depuis plusieurs
années maintenant ce sont les régions
qui font qu'ils sont là qui sont
responsables de ces projets c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans la future pac
et j'en ai parlé avec le président morin
avec les gens de france pour la future
pac
il faut absolument un des croisements
des aides totales une simplification et
une clarification
parce que si nous continuons comme cela
les mêmes causes produiront les mêmes
effets et les premiers projets ne seront
pas ne seront pas payés
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes très attachés à ce que l'ensemble
de ces de cette puce est fait depuis
deux ans trois ans il ya des
associations des collectivités locales
qui ont eu des actes d'engagement et qui
ne sont toujours pas payés ce n'est pas
normal donc nous intervenons auprès de
l'europe pour que les choses puissent
accélérer et nous travaillons
constamment avec hervé morin et régions
de france afin d'essayer de voir comment
nous pourrions régler le problème de
façon plus plus rapide mais
malheureusement je crains madame la
sénatrice maryse carrère que je ne
puisse pas vous rassurer enfin essayons
ensemble de faire en sorte que les
actions engagées par légale puissent
être payés dans le temps imparti je vous
remercie madame carrère il vous reste
quatorze secondes pour une réponse oui
merci monsieur le ministre même si vous
nous rassurer pas je pense vraiment
sincèrement qu'il faut réfléchir à
simplification de ces fonds
en réduisant les échelons décisionnels
et en donnant davantage de pouvoirs aux
régions elles ont aujourd'hui une
autorité de gestion
donnons-leur aujourd'hui l'autorité de
financement merci la parole est à madame
laurence cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes pour
deux minutes il madame la présidente à
la veille du 8 mars journée
internationale de lutte pour les droits
des femmes les femmes n'ont toujours pas
obtenu l'égalité professionnelle qui
passe par un salaire égal à celui des
hommes pour un travail de valeur égale
26% - en moyenne en france
faut-il encore le rappeler pourtant leur
seul à l'arsenal législatif existe pour
parvenir à l'égalité professionnelle
tout récemment les mobilisations des
femmes des associations féministes et
des organisations syndicales unies ont
permis d'obtenir une avancée en matière
d'égalité salariale avec la mise en
place d'une obligation de résultats pour
les entreprises
la ministérielle pénicaud ya contribué
comme elle s'y était engagée ici même
lors de l'examen de la loi liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel
hélas dispositions après disposition le
décret vide de son efficacité le
dispositif que nous avions voté en
juillet dernier pourquoi avoir retenu
madame la ministre des modalités de
construction de cet index de l'égalité
salariale qui permet aux entreprises de
dissimuler écarts de rémunération allant
ainsi à l'encontre du pouvoir législatif
la parole est à madame agnès pannier rue
lâché secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
l'avait bien dit les femmes représentent
50 % de la population active
elle ne contribue qu'à 37 % du pib sont
payés 9% deux mois à fonction égale et
26% - sur le temps d'une carrière
selon le women's forum au rythme actuel
il faudrait attendre 2234 pour atteindre
une part fait preuve parité nous
refaisons d'attendre deux siècles
c'est pour cette raison que la loi pour
la liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel de septembre 2018 prévoit
désormais une obligation de résultat et
une transparence des entreprises sur ces
questions l'index pour l'égalité
professionnelle permet cette
transparence il a été élaboré avec les
partenaires sociaux comme vous le savez
été unanimement saluée lors de sa sortie
cet index ne porte pas que sur l'égalité
salariale mais aussi sur les chances de
carrière et de promotion il porte aussi
sur la parentalité avec l'item
spécifique des congés maternité
il est exigeant puisque 118 entreprises
sur les 732 de plus de 1000 salariés
sont en alerte rouge et quelques 600 ou
montrent des progrès à faire sur les
premiers résultats publiés
il est assorti d'une sanction qui peut
aller jusqu'à 1 % de la masse salariale
pour que les engagements pris par les
entreprises ne soient pas en chocolat
il est également propice à un dialogue
social dans l'entreprise puisqu'il
laisse un temps d'adaptation aux
entreprises pour converger vers une
parité parfaite
je crois que ces éléments témoignent de
l'engagement sans faille de l'ensemble
du gouvernement pour la parité hommes
femmes
je vais l'appuyer par les engagements
complémentaires qui ont été pris par un
certain nombre de sociétés jambes pour
un certain nombre de sociétés
volontaires pour afficher le taux dans
le cadre de taux de femmes à tous les
niveaux de l'entreprise et de s'engager
pour chaque poste d'encadrement a publié
une avoir une candidate femme est une
candidate hommes ce qui est la meilleure
façon de nourrir le vivier est de
promouvoir les femmes dans l'entreprise
je vous remercie madame cohen vous avez
57 secondes pour y madame la ministre
vous parler de sanctions financières
pour les entreprises contrevenantes mais
c'est de la poudre aux yeux
en réalité vous avez choisi des
indicateurs qui rendent invisibles les
discriminations et quasi inopérante les
sanctions que vous avez rendu de fait
exceptionnel pire vous avez même
introduit un seuil de tolérance de
violation de la loi les femmes qui
manifestent dans la rue depuis des mois
pour obtenir plus de pouvoir d'achat en
exigeant notamment une hausse des
salaires et des minima sociaux ne
peuvent se satisfaire d'un tel tour de
passe passe comme les organisations
syndicales les associations féministes
qui dénoncent la précarité le recours au
temps partiel imposé et demandent la
revalorisation des métiers de
prédominance féminine
je serai dans la rue à leurs côtés
demain à 15h40 heure symbolique pour
dénoncer le travail gratuit effectués
quotidiennement par les femmes
à l'heure où le gouvernement cherche
des financements effet la poche des
pauvres l'égalité salariale rapporterait
selon la fondation concorde 62 milliards
d'euros mais cher collègue à l'économie
française
alors madame la ministre
qu'attendez-vous pas de belles paroles
des actes la parole est à madame corinne
féret pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
merci madame la présidente
mes chers collègues ma question était
destiné à madame la ministre du travail
mais je vois que c'est madame
darrieussecq qui va y répondre
madame la ministre la crise sociale
profonde qui traverse notre pays ces
derniers mois jette une lumière crue sur
l'ampleur et l'aggravation des
inégalités dans notre société et il
suffit d'observer les cortèges qui
défilent dans les rues pour constater
que les femmes sont particulièrement
frappés par cette précarité
en cette veille du 8 mars journée
internationale des femmes il est
impossible de ne pas s'indigner que
l'égalité des chances tant recherchée ne
s'opère pas avec la même force que l'on
soit un homme ou une femme
et les chiffres sont têtus même
implacable
cela a été dit mais c'est bien de le
répéter aujourd'hui en france à poste
égal une femme touchera en moyenne 9 %
de salaire de moins qu'un homme
dans l'ensemble de sa carrière son
salaire sera moins 25 % inférieur à
celui d'un homme
nous sommes je le sais est unanime pour
condamner une telle inégalité
mais où sont les actes madame la
ministre vous avez créé un index de
l'égalité femmes/hommes attribuant
entreprises de plus de 1000 salariés une
note
si l'intention est louable nous nous
pouvons que regretter le manque
d'ambition de cette mesure
pourquoi en effet la limiter aux grandes
entreprises quand plus de 48 % de
l'emploi salarié se trouve dans les pme
mais surtout comment comment cet
indicateur si les entreprises s'évalue
henman et quant au 1er mars
seule la moitié des entreprises s'est
plié à cette obligation
l'indispensable lutte contre les
inégalités ne peut se réduire à un
tableau de chiffres
elle doit passer par une politique
volontariste et coercitives sanctionnant
les discriminations avec la plus grande
sévérité nous
vont plus accepter comme le démontre une
étude publiée par votre ministère
l'année dernière que 62 % des femmes ont
connu et connaîtront la précarité
professionnelle au cours de leur
carrière contre seulement 32% des hommes
madame la ministre alors que le
président de la république a déclaré que
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
devaient creuser en cause de son
capitaine à quelle est la réalité
la vérité c'est que le budget consacré à
cette lutte ne représente que 80
millions de ruraux et soit 000 66 % du
budget ma question est donc simple
quelles mesures comptez-vous prendre
enfin pour être à la hauteur des
engagements pris devant la nation
sa parole est à madame geneviève
darrieussecq secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre des armées
merci madame la présidente mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
vous l'avez dit oui les choses sont
préoccupantes
les femmes sont les premières victimes
de la pauvreté
du travail partiel subi des métiers sous
payés des inégalités salariales
ce sont les mères isolées qui souvent
sont en grande difficulté
les petites retraites également on les a
entendues partout en france et notamment
sur les ronds points
c'est un constat et oui la grande cause
nationale de ce quinquennat c'est
d'égalité homme-femme et oui nous
faisons tout pour agir dans ce domaine
où nous avons à mon sens dans ce pays
pris beaucoup de retard
nous agissons pour créer les conditions
d'accès de réussite des femmes au même
titre que les hommes bien sûr mixité des
filières avec notamment la fondation
france numérique égalité salariale on
vient d'en parler avec agnès pannier qui
a développé le sujet dans le privé mais
également dans le public avec la
création d'un fonds en faveur de
l'égalité professionnelle dans la
fonction publique qui a été lancé il ya
quelques jours par olivier du sorte
del entendu cela passe aussi par un
travail important sur la conciliation
entre vie professionnelle et vie
personnelle
les congés de maternité améliorer
l'évolution des modes de garde d'enfants
la transparence dans l'attribution des
places en crèche
ça passe également par l'entrepreneuriat
au féminin avec le réseau des
ambassadrices de l'entrepreneuriat le
gouvernement a engagé les banques à
mieux financer les entrepreneurs les
nominations paritaire et j'ai écrit il a
été envoyé un courrier en ce sens à tous
le gouvernement afin de travailler sur
ce sujet et puis bien sûr nous devons
vaincre le sexisme et les violences
sexuelles et sexistes qui gangrène tous
les milieux alors c'est un combat
culturel
c'est un combat culturel il nous faut
mener à tous les niveaux leur est
notamment démarré par le niveau de
l'éducation
je crois que c'est un combat que nous
mènerons tous ensemble la parole est à
monsieur jérôme bignon pour le groupe
les indépendants république et
territoires pour deux minutes
merci madame la présidente le président
macron l'a affirmé au salon de
l'agriculture l'europe doit avoir une
politique agricole basée sur trois
piliers forts protéger transformer
anticipé le groupe allemand sud du caire
en restructurant son outil industriel
saint louis sucre en france enfermement
en fermant et peuvent ils dans la somme
mais en cause le pilier protection et le
pilier anticipation pas le moindre
préavis
pas la moindre concertation heureusement
que la france et l'allemagne sont
étroitement unie par différents traités
de coopération
le dernier signe à aix la chapelle
heureusement que la pac existe depuis le
traité de rome
qu'en serait-il autrement à la veille
des élections européennes
ce capitalisme débridé n'illustre pas de
façon positive la coopération pourtant
ce pourtant souvent ventés entre nos
deux pays
cette décision si elle devient effective
condamne d'importants bassins de
production de betteraves dans la somme
pas seulement dans l'aisne dans l'oise
dans le pas de calais dégrade 1275
exploitations agricoles soit plus de 20
mille hectares
tout l'écosystème local mais plus de 600
emplois directs et indirects et
déstabilisé et remis en cause et
salariés de l'usiné les transporteurs
les sous-traitants les commerces locaux
les entrepreneurs agricoles sont
violemment impactés il s'agit
aujourd'hui de préserver l'intégrité
d'une filière française qui contribuent
chaque année pour 1,3 milliard d'euros
réduire le déficit de notre balance
commerciale c'est impératif de s'y
engager le gouvernement doit tout mettre
en oeuvre pour éviter cette décision qui
mettrait en danger une filière
performante durement affecté par la fin
des quotas et la chute des prix
mardi vous avez dit monsieur le ministre
à l'assemblée que le sujet est grave et
qu'il fallait réagir
je suis d'accord avec vous vous avez dit
également négocié avec la commission
européenne et vous avez proposé aux
députés les associer aux réunions de
travail avec la filière le sénat
aimerait être associé à ces réunions
au même titre que l'assemblée nationale
pourriez-vous enfin nous dire si depuis
mardi ce dossier a pu avancer et quelles
sont les pistes ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jérôme bignon la question que
vous posez une question grave grave pour
la filière sucrière et bat betteravière
de france même si je veux affirmer ici
que malgré ces décisions la filière
betteravière dans son ensemble n'est pas
en danger
elle pourra continuer à affirmer la
décision unilatérale de soude suggère de
fermer trois sites où quasiment de les
fermer est absolument inacceptable
cani dans calvados concerne 1100
planteurs 85 emplois directs supprimés
et peuvent ils dans la somme
1400 planteurs centre de cent trente
deux emplois directs supprimés 122
seraient transférés et à marseille 58
salariés dont 5 seulement seraient
seraient maintenus nous avons donc
travaillé avec l'ensemble des 2 de la
filière les réunions sont tenues avec
l'ensemble des coopératives
cet après midi à 17 heures remise sur
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
l'ensemble des parlementaires
concerné surtout les bancs sont invités
pour une réunion de concertation
parce que je veux jouer la transparence
la plus totale parce que dans une
opération comme celle là c'est par la
transparence c'est en nous serrant les
coudes en travaillant avec les acteurs
de la filière que nous y arriverons vous
avez été plusieurs à m'interpeller
directement vous même monsieur le
sénateur daniel dubois corinne féret ça
m'est égal y est et d'autre et je crois
que nous devons avancer dans une botte
dans une seule et même direction
aujourd'hui nous devons affirmer que
nous ne pouvons pas laisser faire les
choses en l'état la semaine prochaine
avec mon collègue bruno le maire doit le
rencontrer la direction et le président
dessus du coeur afin de radés vraiment
quelles sont les intentions de cette
coopérative
je rappelle que ces 17% de la filière
betteravière qui est qui est concerné et
nous voulons aller plus loin il est
question de réorientation de
réorganisation de cette filière
nous travaillons avec le président et
l'ensemble de la filière sucrière
la situation est grave mais elle est
prise en compte par vous même je ne sais
monsieur bignon par l'ensemble des
sénateurs ici par l'ensemble des
parlementaires et le gouvernement sera
au rendez vous pour accompagner la
filière pour grand peiné par les
parlementaires
et pour négocier avec l'entreprise
soccer je vous remercie monsieur mignon
pour 8 secondes
ces dix pour ça on enlève la présente ce
capitalisme sauvage entre états membres
ces intérêts court terme ils ces
distorsions de concurrence ces usages
des voiliers de l'argent public ne sont
pas acceptables dans un marché unique
européen
ce non respect des planteurs et des
travailleurs n'est pas acceptable
néanmoins merci monsieur le ministre
pour votre réponse la parole est à m e
jean jacques panunzi pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
madame la ministre la corse a été le
premier territoire français à se doter
d'une pp en 2015
elle avait fait l'objet d'un travail de
convergence d'un vote à l'assemblée de
corse et d'un décret ministériel 7 pp
permettait d'appréhender les prospective
énergétique de la corse en misant sur
une vraie politique d'efficacité
énergétique une meilleure intégration
des énergies renouvelables dans le mix
énergétique tout en prenant en compte la
vétusté de certains moyens de près du
production comme la centrale du vazzio
interconnexion entre la corse et
l'italie
aujourd'hui nous constatons que cette
paix peut unanimement saluée au niveau
national comme local mans qui avait
obtenu toutes les validations des
différentes commissions nationales et
qui avait réussi à obtenir l'accord de
la majorité des parties prenantes en
corse semble être remise en question
j'en veux pour preuve la lettre envoyée
à la collectivité de corse par nicolas
hulot alors ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire envoyé juste
avant sa démission ainsi que les
commentaires des uns et des autres dans
les médias
suite à la dernière rencontre que vous
avez eue avec l'exécutif régional
madame la ministre pourriez vous nous
faire savoir quelles sont les intentions
du gouvernement concernant la prochaine
pp en corse notamment au regard des
éléments majeurs présents dans
l'actuelle ppe sachant qu'il y a urgence
et que les corses n'accepterons jamais
une prolongation des anciens moyens de
production qui doivent normalement être
déclassées en 2023 notamment l'actuel
central du vase qui est un outil
vieillissant sujet de nombreux incidents
et fonctionnant actuellement au fioul
lourd aller au delà de 2023 avec de tels
outils mettrait à l'évidence en risque
l'alimentation de la corse et
impliquerait
de poursuivre un fonctionnement fut
lourd ce qui est inacceptable pour la
population du pays ajaccien
plus précisément madame la ministre
pouvez vous nous dire si oui ou non le
gouvernement a l'intention de respecter
le décret du 10 décembre 2015 relatif à
la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie en corse qui prévoyait la
réalisation d'une infrastructure
d'alimentation en gaz naturel de la
corse
l'action avec un objectif de mise en
service au plus tard depuis 2000 23 d'un
cycle combiné d'une puissance de 250
mégawatts et la conversion des moyens
thermiques existantes perso naturel je
vous remettre la parole à madame
jacqueline gourault au ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur panunzi la corse fait l'objet
comme vous venez de le rappeler du fait
de son insularité d'une programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie à part et
d'une attention particulière du
gouvernement pour la sécurité de ses
approvisionnements énergétiques
aujourd'hui vous l'avez rappelé à tire
de son électricité provient de centrales
thermique à fuel située à ajaccio et à
bastia qui sont vieillissantes et
polluantes
la ppe de 2015 a prévu que ces
installations seraient remplacées par
des centrales à gaz
à cet effet un projet consistait à
installer une barge de gaz à bastia et
de relier cette dernière par un gazoduc
traversant la corse jusqu'à ajaccio pour
alimenter la deuxième centrale
les difficultés sont son nom cependant
très nombreuses comme vous le savez
monsieur le sénateur en particulier
parce que le trajet du gazoduc doit
passer non seulement au travers de la
montagne mais aux milliers de parcelles
privées au régime particulièrement
complexe en corse comme vous le savez
nous avons
quand je dis nous c'est bien sûr le
ministre d'état ministre de l'écologie
et de la transit de la transition
écologique et solidaire pardon a reçu
très récemment et j'ai été présente à ce
rendez vous le président simeone et nous
avons exprimé à cet effet les doutes sur
la faisabilité de ce projet du gazoduc
et envisager de nouvelles pistes qui
pourraient passer par là l'installation
d'un second terminal de gaz
potentiellement immergé en mer au large
d'ajaccio
le gouvernement est résolu à tenir ses
engagements dans la nouvelle ppe et bien
sûr veut s'assurer du renforcement de la
sécurité énergétique de la corse tout en
développant les énergies renouvelables
la parole est à madame annick billon
pour le groupe union centriste
merci madame après
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à la
secrétaire d'état en charge de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et de la
lutte contre les discriminations en
novembre 2010 est le prénom ce président
annonçait vouloir faire de l'égalité
entre les hommes et des femmes
la grande cause nationale de son
quinquennat et en cette veille du 8 mars
je souhaiterais évoqué la question
alarmante des féminicides le taux de
femmes tuées s'accélère de façon
inquiétante depuis le début de cette
année en effet depuis janvier 2019 30
femmes ont été tuées par leur conjoint
ou ex conjoint
c'est deux fois plus que l'année
précédente à la même période elles sont
plus de 200 avoir succombé ces dernières
années plus généralement environ 225
mille femmes sont victimes de violences
conjugales physiques ou sexuelles en
2018 dans le sillage de la sphère wayne
stein les plaintes pour viol augmenté de
près de 17% et celle pour agression
sexuelle ont bondi de 20%
or le nombre de condamnations effectives
lui stagne on le sait la formation des
personnels de police sur ces questions
dans est qu'à ses balbutiements
par ailleurs la délivrance d'ordonnancé
de protection pour les juges aux
affaires familiales en principe
accessibles à toutes les victimes de
violence conjugale sans nécessiter des
dépôts de plainte préalable est loin
d'être systématique la lutte contre les
violences conjugales doit être
appréhendée de manière globale en
incluant les individus les travailleurs
sociaux les magistrats les forces de
l'ordre les associations selon le lâcher
seuls 80 millions d'euros des crédits
sur les 420 millions pour l'égalité sont
alloués chaque année à la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes
il faudrait cinq fois plus de moyens car
la mise en place de politiques publiques
à réel impact sur la hausse ou la baisse
du nombre de victimes
c'est pourquoi je vous pose la question
à la veille de cette journée hautement
symbolique
le gouvernement se donne t'il réellement
les moyens de lutter contre les
féminicides je remercie la parole est à
madame agnès plus
un ministre des solidarités et de la
santé merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice mme pardon madame la
présidente annick billon veuillez
pardonner l'absence de ma collègue la
ministre madame chapeau
je vais répondre à sa place concernant
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
vous le savez c'est la grande pause du
quinquennat et nous avons pris un
certain nombre de mesures depuis notre
arrivée puisque s'il s'agit d'une
politique largement interministérielle
qui est porté de façon volontariste par
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
plus de cent mesures concrètes ont déjà
été prises
j'en citerai quelques unes et vous le
savez les moyens financiers sont
conséquents puisque 3 530 millions
d'euros ont été inscrits au plf 2010 9
donc c'est un budget important je crois
le plus important jamais dédiée à cette
cause de l'égalité entre les femmes et
des hommes vous le savez la yamaha dans
sa loi portait la création du délit d'
outrage sexies permettant de fermer 10
et le harcèlement de rue et nous sommes
le premier pays au monde à mettre en
oeuvre cette mesure
cela fonctionne en six mois plus de 330
amendes ont été infligées allant jusqu'à
750 euros et ce dispositif fera l'objet
d'une évaluation parlementaire à partir
du début de l'été ce qui permettra de
proposer d'éventuelles correctifs par
ailleurs je pense aussi à la loi portée
par muriel pénicaud sur l'égalité
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
mais vous m'interrogez sur les violences
faites aux femmes sur les féminicides
nous sommes engagés très rapidement sur
la création de centres de prise en
charge du psycho traumatismes notamment
dédié aux femmes victimes de violences
sexuelles est fictive victimes de
violence tout court de leur conjoint
nous avons fait un appel à projets
l'appel à candidatures l'année dernière
ces dix centres ont été créés labellisés
nous sommes le premier pays au monde
organiser des réseaux de prise en charge
des victimes de psycho traumatisme c'est
une mesure emblématique sur lequel il y
avait un engagement du président de la
république lors du lancement de novembre
2017 et donc le gouvernement est
totalement mobilisée pour réduire
évidemment les violences faites aux
femmes je vous remercie
la parole est à madame josiane cost pour
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
et social européen
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
transports madame la ministre
comme vous le savez le groupe rds se est
très préoccupé par les questions de
mobilité et la nécessité d'agir
efficacement pour améliorer la desserte
des territoires fragiles et victime
donnant donnant clairement mortifère
souvent à la fois routier ferroviaire et
aérien et même numérique
le sénat a voté le 20 février 2019 par
305 voix
la proposition de loi du rds relatives à
ce sujet capital pour ces territoires et
nous attendons avec espoir que la loi
mobilité reprennent en grande partie ces
propositions largement partagé un des
sujets abordés par la proposition de loi
et le transport aérien régional et en
particulier les lignes d'aménagement du
territoire
certes vous avez prévu un effort
budgétaire et nous le salut en méforme
et sur le terrain force est de constater
que la qualité de plus en plus
déplorable du service rendu aux usagers
annulation fréquentes retard mettant
parfois en jeu leur sécurité
et ce en dépit du prix prohibitifs des
billets et du film financement public
etat collectivités de constater le quasi
monopole d'une compagnie nationale pour
laquelle ces liaisons sont
malheureusement considérées comme
secondaires voire comme une charge
il n'est pas concevable qu'en 2019 que
nos compatriotes habitant dans ces
territoires particulièrement fragiles
soient traités de la sorte
madame la ministre deux questions
simples prendrez-vous en considération
au cours du débat sur la loi l'homme le
contenu de la proposition de loi votée
par le sénat
au delà des efforts financiers que nous
saluons quelle mesure entendez vous
mettre en
las pour que les lignes aériennes
d'aménagement du territoire permettent
aux voyageurs de bénéficier d'un prix et
d'une qualité de service digne de ce nom
la parole est à madame elisabeth bornes
ministre chargé des transports
même la présidente mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice
josiane cost j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire lors de l'examen du texte je
partage largement les constats de la
proposition de loi est la loi
d'orientation des mobilités il répondra
concernant les liaisons aériennes
d'aménagement du territoire je suis
convaincu qu elles sont essentielles
pour nos territoires
c'est pour ça que j'ai souhaité relancer
ses liaisons en quadruplant le budget
qui leur est consacré et dès 2019
l'augmentation de ce budget va se
traduire par des améliorations concrètes
à limoges castres quimper poitiers et la
rochelle
nous n'avons donc pas attendu pour agir
et au delà de cet engagement de l'état
il est effectivement primordial de
redresser la qualité de service de ces
dessertes et nous sommes fortement
mobilisée pour cela il y a plusieurs
mois j'ai demandé un programme d'actions
à hope qui a permis notamment de réduire
le nombre d'incidents techniques et donc
le nombre d'annulations et j'ai échangé
avec le nouveau directeur général d'air
france klm avec la nouvelle directrice
générale d'air france qui sont
pleinement conscients de la nécessité
d'améliorer la qualité de service sur
ces liaisons
ainsi l'organisation et la gestion des
vols va être repris directement par air
france et les appareils de type atr vont
être retirés de la flotte en 2020 au
demeurant ces liaisons sont remises
régulièrement en concurrence et on peut
donc espérer que ce soit l'occasion
d'améliorer la qualité de service donc
je peux vous assurer madame la sénatrice
que le gouvernement est pleinement
mobilisé pour assurer une meilleure
qualité de service sur cette liaison
essentielle pour nos territoires
madame cost il vous reste neuf secondes
merci madame la ministre pour votre
réponse les habitants de ces territoires
attendent vraiment une amélioration de
service les entreprises également parce
que nombre de rendez vous d'affaires son
manque est dû à des annulations ou des
retards et c'est absolument important
pour l'activité économique de nos de nos
territoires donc je vous remercie en
attend une amélioration avec impatience
merci la parole est à madame laurence
arrivée pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
[Applaudissements]
en 2017 le gouvernement avait fait de la
réindustrialisation une priorité mais
les faits sont cruels 850 emplois rayés
de la carte chez ford 450 chez ask ovale
suspendus à des plans de reprise 750 à
la fonderie du poitou 900 sur les sites
sarthois papetier d'arjowiggins
la liste n'est pas close le gouvernement
a trouvé un digne l'attitude de ford et
s'est dit tromper dans la reprise
avortée d'arc ovale au delà de
l'indignation quelle est la colonne
vertébrale de la politique industrielle
pourquoi se désengager d'industries
stratégiques alors que d'autres font le
contraire des états unis à la chine
comme en europe
sur ce point les reproches envers les
pays bas vis-à-vis de air france klm
étonne au regard de l'énergie déployée
pour privatiser quelques fleurons
profitable à l'exemple des aéroports de
paris où est cette priorité à la rentrée
industrialisation madame le ministre
y at il une un état stratège
la parole est à madame agnès pannier rue
nasser secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
d'abord les faits sont têtus la france
la france crée aujourd'hui plus
d'emplois industriels qu'elle n'en
détruit la france ouvre plus de sites et
en développe plus qu'elle n'en ferme et
cette situation est nouvelle depuis deux
ans car eh oui
lindt et les statistiques les faits sont
têtus les chiffres aussi et si je peux
continuer depuis 20 ans vous depuis 20
ans l'emploi industriel a diminué d'un
million un million et depuis deux ans il
progresse et pourquoi parce que nous
avons mis en place une politique
industrielle ambitieuse
premièrement une politique a dû une
politique la douce réel qui permet le
développement de l'activité économique
en rendant la plateforme françaises plus
compétitives
c'est ça qui explique que toyota
investit 300 millions d'euros en france
daimler 500 millions d'euros en france
et que nous sommes désormais la première
destination des investissements directs
à l'étranger pour l'industrie une aide
d'une politique industrielle qui
développe des constats stratégique de
filière pour 18 filières avec des
projets d'innovation des projets de
compétences et quel est le premier point
de blocage pour les emplois industriels
c'est le recrutement madame c'est ça qui
empêche la croissance 50 mille emplois
aujourd'hui ne sont pas pourvus dans
l'industrie
deux cent mille si on était capable de
mettre les compétences face aux chefs
d'entreprise ça c'est la réalité
alors oui il y à des guerres compères
sur ford sur blanquefort sur un sco
valent mais pourquoi vous ne parlez pas
des trois des 3000 emplois que nous
avons sauvé j'ai vu williams sauvera des
emplois que nous avons sauvé shaher
industrie d emplois que nous avons sauvé
chez doux trois entreprises sur quatre
en difficulté sont redresser grâce à
l'intensité de l'activité du
gouvernement
ça ce sont les faits madame
madame marie b pour 57 secondes
madame la ministre soyons sérieux
peut-on réduire comme ça a été fait hier
par votre ministre une stratégie
industrielle au fait d'arracher 20
millions à un groupe qui en a touché 24
plus 500 millions de cic eux comme ce
fut le cas pour forme permet permettez
nous de vous proposer quelques pistes de
travail
osons des prises de participation
temporaire en cas de crise comme l'a
fait le président obama pour general
motors ou la france dans d'autres temps
pour peugeot
responsabilisons les grands groupes
donneurs d'ordre des pme si renault
pérennise ses commandes à la fonderie du
poitou la reprise devient crédible
appuyons nous sur les régions pour
ancrer au territoire innovation et
industrie du futur et les chiffres que
vous donnez sont en particulier le
résultat des politiques régionales
à l'image de la nouvelle aquitaine avec
usines du foot du futur qui a accompagné
près de 300 entreprises représentant 35
mille emplois en deux ans osons la
coopération induit industrielles
européennes à l'image d'airbus en étant
porteur d'une vision européenne
voilà les pistes sur lesquelles nous
nous sommes prêts à travailler
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame céline voulait sp
rognés pour le groupe l'est républicain
madame le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
le hashtag prisonnière du hidjab
fleurissent sur les réseaux sociaux de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée derrière
il y à des femmes courageuses qui
dénonce le voile comme un instrument
d'oppression
elle pointe du doigt la pression sociale
et l'environnement familial qui les
condamne à se voiler
chez nous aussi la pression des
quartiers et des familles ne lasse en
réalité que peu de choix aux femmes
voilées en particulier aux plus jeunes
d'entre elles alors que les femmes
algériennes nous indique la voie du
courage
la position de votre majorité est sur ce
sujet d'une ambiguïté problématique
or la france nation des droits de
l'homme doit véhiculer un message de
liberté pour les femmes du monde entier
le président de la république le 16
avril 2018 déclaré que le voile n'était
pas conforme à la civilité qu'il ya dans
notre pays le 28 février dernier il se
muer en défenseur du voile expliquant
que les entreprises qui discriminent les
femmes voilées al embauche devait être
sévèrement sanctionnés sur ce sujet
l'exécutif est donc preuve d'angélisme
pire de contradictions pouvez-vous au
nom du gouvernement devant notre
assemblée condamné à nouveau les propos
d'un député de votre majorité qui a
réalisé la semaine dernière un amalgame
surréaliste entre le port du hidjab et
celui du serre tête alors que ce célèbre
demain la journée de la femme il est
essentiel de rappeler que le combat pour
une véritable égalité homme femme passe
aussi par le combat sur notre territoire
de toute forme de fondamentalisme dont
le voile est souvent un étendard
monsieur le premier ministre
le voile est il oui ou non un instrument
d'oppression des femmes et que comptez
vous faire pour protéger toutes ces
femmes qui sur le territoire français
sont contraintes de le porter je vous
remercie
la parole est à madame geneviève
darrieussecq secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre des armées
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice
je rappellerai simplement que nous
sommes dans un pays où la laïcité est la
règle et la laïcité s'inscrit au fronton
de toutes nos mairies et au fronton de
toutes nos institutions
je crois que nous devons respecter
également la volonté de chacun de porter
ou non les attributs vestimentaires
qu'il souhaite porter dans l'espace
public
je dis bien dans l'espace public
pour le reste moi je préférerais que
nous nous dirigions vers ce que nous
mettons en oeuvre au niveau de ce
gouvernement c'est à dire une vraie
diplomatie féministe afin que nous
puissions partager nos convictions avec
de façon universelle sur les violences
faites aux femmes sur les contraintes
faites aux femmes sur l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes sur
l'émancipation des femmes qui sont des
concepts qui à notre sens doivent être
des concepts universels et qui nécessite
un engagement de toutes et tous
je crois sur le plan national et sur le
plan international
et c'est dans ce sens que marlène
schiappa travail
c'est dans ce sens également que le
président de la république remettra le
prix simone veil qui récompense les
actions en faveur des droits des femmes
dans le monde et c'est dans ce sens
également que sera travaillé au niveau
de la présidence du g7 l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes parce que ce
dont vous me parlez madame c'est une
question d'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes et pour nous cela est
absolument essentiel mais je le rappelle
cela doit s'inscrire dans notre pays
dans un esprit de laïcité qui est la
règle en france dans notre république
française
merci madame vous l'espériez pour
quelques petites secondes
madame la ministre je prends acte de
votre réponse j'ai bien peur qu'elle
soit en total décalage avec le sens de
mon message
vous devez vous devez réaffirmer les
valeurs d'universalisme qui font l'adn
de la france vous devez nommer les
problèmes pour mieux les combattre et le
relativisme qui fait l'apanage de votre
gouvernance depuis le départ est une
mauvaise réponse à de vrais problèmes je
vous demande d'y réfléchir
il est temps il est temps vraiment la
parole est à madame nathalie goulet pour
le groupe union centriste
oui mais la présidente 1 messieurs les
ministres mes chers amis chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à madame b loubet
j'ai bien entendu la question de notre
collègue mohamed soilihi j'ai aussi
madame la garde des sceaux entendu votre
réponse pardonnez-moi si en tant que
sénateur de l'orne je n'ai pas
exactement la même vision de la
situation
évidemment je m'associe à la solidarité
qui a été exprimée à l'égard des
victimes de cet attentat
mais je veux dire que nous sommes entre
colère et découragement comprendre
l'improbable et surréaliste régime des
fouilles
alors que plus de 90 mille objets madame
la garde des sceaux tt trouvé cette
année quarante mille téléphones sont
entrés dans les prisons en 2017
orient ne parle même pas de la
créativité des détenus a créé des armes
par destination avec tout ce qui leur
passe par la main sans compter que nous
n'avons toujours pas de gilet par l'âme
pour les gardiens et le personnel
pénitentiaire comment expliquer
également l'accès à une unité de vie
familiale pour un criminel de cette
nature et j'ajoute deux fois par mois
comment expliquer les failles du
renseignement pénitentiaire alors que ce
détenu était été signalé pour ces faits
de radicalisation madame la ministre la
question que je voudrais vous poser
c'est quel calendrier et quelles mesures
avez-vous l'intention de prendre pour
que nos personnels pénitentiaires soient
mieux protégés qu'il n'est surtout pas
le sentiment que le confort des détenus
passent avant leur sécurité
la parole est à madame nicole belloubet
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
madame la présidente
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice goulet je
connais votre réflexion sur la question
de la radicalisation j'ai d'ailleurs eu
l'occasion de lire ce que vous aviez
écrit hier et avant-hier sur ce sujet je
voudrais ici vous assurer que la
détermination du gouvernement pour
lutter contre la radicalisation en
prison est totale et je ne peux pas les
jeux ne peuvent pas vous laisser dire
des choses qui restent à l'encontre de
cette détermination je mets trois
arguments à l'appui de mon propos tout
d'abord nous avons agi pour prendre en
charge ces personnes radicaliser vous me
demandez un calendrier je vous le donne
depuis le mois de janvier dernier
nous avons développé des processus
d'évaluation de la radicalisation ils
sont en cours de déploiement nous avons
aujourd'hui cinq quartiers d'évaluation
de la radicalisation
là où il n'y en avait que de l'année
dernière nous avons ensuite mis en place
un système qui permet d'affecter ces
détenus radicaliser dans des lieux qui
sont adaptés
ce sont des quartiers d'isolement ou des
quartiers de prévention de la
radicalisation tout état de cause des
quartiers étanche du reste de la
détention pour éviter le prosélytisme
mais cela se constitue sur le construit
progressive
ensuite nous avons essayé le deuxième
point sur lequel je voudrais insister
nous avons renforcé la sécurité des
établissements
nous déployons un système de brouillage
nouveau des téléphones portables nous
commençons à le déployer à la prison de
la santé à vendin le vieil
et nous allons continuer nous avons un
dispositif de lutte contre les drones
nous avons accru de plus de 16% le
budget de sécurité des établissements
pénitentiaires et nous allons continuer
nous avons enfin pris des mesures c'est
le troisième point pour protéger nos
personnels pénitentiaires ces mesures de
protection contrairement à ce que vous
avez affirmé à l'instant passe notamment
par le déploiement d'équipements nouveau
gilet pare-balles tenu par coup plus de
1500 gillet par pardon par l'âme
excusez-moi pas par balles par l'âme
plus de 1500 gillet ont été déployés
cela doit continuer et il ya également
d'autres mesures qui sont prises dans ce
sens la sécurité des français et notre
priorité celles des personnels
pénitentiaires l'est tout autant madame
la sénatrice madame boulet madame boulet
madame la garde des sceaux je ne doute
pas du tout de votre détermination je
sais qu'il ya pas de baguette magique il
n'ya pas non plus de recettes parce que
sinon ça fait longtemps que le sénat
aurait y trouver des solutions nous
avons été très solidaire de l'ensemble
des mesures contre le terrorisme qui ont
été votées ces dernières années ce que
je voulais simplement indiqué c'est que
la radicalisation en prison ne date pas
d'hier elle ne date pas non plus de
votre gouvernement farhad khosrokhavar
l'a dénoncée depuis extrêmement
longtemps on sait qu'il faut du temps au
temps et ça c'est normal mais vous voyez
que les personnels ont comme manque
quand même d'équipement il manque aussi
de formation quant à l'évaluation qui
est un sujet majeur à la fois pour la
prévention mais aussi pour les gens qui
sont en prison veuillez croire que nous
nous cherchons des dispositifs qui
permettent cette évaluation qui est
absolument déterminant pour juger de la
dangerosité
surtout que nous allons avoir des
encombrants qui arrive de saint guiral
tôt et que nous savons pas comment les
traiter
la parole est à madame catherine dumas
pour le groupe l'est républicain
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères ministre de tutelle
d'atout france organisme en charge de la
promotion de la destination touristique
france à l'étranger
il semble en effet qu'une note interne
au quai d'orsay envisage un plan
d'économies drastique
atout france entraînant un plan social
de grande ampleur ayant pour conséquence
de réduire d'un tiers la masse salariale
également d'économiser près de 4
millions d'euros
l'opérateur business france d'ailleurs
seraient aussi concernés alors
évidemment nous ne sommes pas contre 2
nécessaires économies dans l' usage des
deniers publics bien au contraire
mais convenez monsieur le ministre que
cette coupe claire entraînerait la
fermeture de plusieurs bureaux à
l'étranger
quel impact aurait grandement les
missions de rayonnement d'attractivité
des destinations françaises dont atout
france a la charge
alors que notre pays subit depuis
plusieurs semaines une dégradation de
son image auprès des touristes étrangers
en raison des mouvements sociaux de
grande ampleur que nous subissons
ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre quelles sont vos ambitions pour
la promotion du tourisme auprès des
clientèles étrangères
la parole est à monsieur marc fesneau
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice d'humains le tourisme est un
secteur clé pour notre économie en même
temps qu'un instrument d' influence
majeure à l'étranger c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement fait du développement
touristique de l'ensemble des
destinations françaises l'une de ses
priorités
les objectifs que nous nous sommes fixés
en terme de fréquentation et de
retombées économiques sur les prochaines
années sont ambitieux à ce titre les
résultats de 2018 sont à cet égard
encourageants avec près de 90 millions
de touristes étrangers mais nous devons
encore faire davantage et atout france
est au coeur évidemment de cette
stratégie vous évoquer la question des
moyens
les grandes orientations données par le
gouvernement dans le cadre d'actions
publiques 2022 impliqueront
nécessairement et c'est logique une
transformation de la présence
internationale de l'état de ses opéras
heures et donc d'atout france en
évaluant l'efficacité de l'action de
chacun nous aurons donc très rapidement
rapidement à mener une réflexion
stratégique sur la manière meilleure
manière pardon d'utiliser la promotion
d'assurer la promotion touristique de
nos destinations à l'étranger avec atout
france et ses partenaires publics et
privés
mais en ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement le financement de la
promotion touristique
le gouvernement s'est clairement engagé
lors du conseil interministériel du
tourisme du 19 janvier dernier deal 2018
pardon en apportant des ressources
supplémentaires pérennes notamment par
le biais de la recette visa le ministre
livre le drian et le secrétaire d'état
jean baptiste lemoyne resteront
mobilisés pour que les collectivités les
professionnels et l'état rassemble leur
énergie et leurs moyens en faveur de la
promotion des destinations dans un
modèle partenarial qui caractérise notre
politique touristique et qu'incarne
atout france le gouvernement a également
conforté atout france dans sa mission
d'appui à la structuration de nos offres
touristiques
c'est le sens de la mise en place du
dispositif france tourisme a généré
porté par atout france et la banque des
territoires qui accompagne les
collectivités locales dans la
structuration de projets touristiques
d'envergure à même de répondre à une
demande mondiale toujours plus exigeante
c'est en effet en agissant à la fois sur
la demande et sur l'offre que nous
pourrons atteindre nos objectifs de
fréquentation et de recettes
touristiques et à faire mais plus encore
la vocation touristique de notre pays et
permettent que ce secteur soit l'un des
vecteurs de la croissance et de l'emploi
je vous remercie madame dumas pour 42
secondes
oui il monsieur le ministre on j'ai bien
entendu votre réponse vous réaffirmer
votre ambition pour l'évolution du
tourisme dans notre pays je m'en réjouis
mais justement vous parlez du conseil
interministériel du tourisme j'en suis
membre
et c'est justement à cet effet que je
vous redis qu'un vaste plan social
atout france serait un paradoxe au
regard de l'objectif en quantité en
qualité que le gouvernement a fixé
également un paradoxe
aussi au regard de la concurrence de
plus en plus vives
d'autres destinations en europe et dans
le reste du monde
la parole est à monsieur stéphane pinoit
pour le groupe les républicains pour
minutes merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre après un début de
quinquennat exécuté à marche forcée nous
constatons tous ici un net
ralentissement de la marche depuis le 15
janvier
le temps législatif est figé et on ne
compte plus les projets de lois reporter
et les réformes suspendus aux
conclusions du grand débat national
plus grave sans doute encore le travail
parlementaire est désormais balayé d'un
revers de manche par votre gouvernement
ainsi le 11 décembre dernier le sénat a
voté à une très large majorité une
proposition de loi portée par notre
collègue françoise gatel rapportés par
agnès canayer proposition de loi qui
visait à apporter de la souplesse au
fonctionnement et à l'organisation des
communes nouvelles qui rappelons le
concerne 2 millions près de deux
millions et demi de français dans 757 55
communes nouvelles vous avez en tout cas
le gouvernement avait soutenu cette
démarche qui est particulièrement
attendu et notamment dans mon
département de maine et loire
hélas nous apprenons cette semaine que
l'examen de ce texte à l'assemblée
nationale qui était inscrit dans
l'agenda de l'assemblée nationale a été
reportée sine aidiez ce qui va à
l'encontre de votre à ganges engagement
madame la ministre
quelles garanties pouvaient pouvez vous
nous apportez pour que ce report ne soit
pas purement et simplement un d'abandon
la parole est à madame jacqueline
gourault ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur vous avez rappelé l'importance
des communes nouvelles qui je le
rappelle ont été créées par la loi de
2010 et réformer en 2015 par le député
jacques pélissard cette politique est un
grand succès puisque aujourd'hui 2500
huit communes se sont regroupés pour
créer sept cent soixante quatorze
communes nouvelles
on peut féliciter dg d'ailleurs ne
serait-ce qu'en 2019 il y en a encore eu
239 en conséquence d'ailleurs le nombre
de communes et d'aujourd'hui de 34 1970
pour être très précise alors on sait
monsieur le sénateur que cette politique
a beaucoup de succès particulièrement
dans l'ouest de la france et notamment
dans le maine-et-loire que vous
représentez ici au sénat mais aussi dans
la manche
dans le calvados et dans l'eure pour
citer ceux qui arrivent en tête
vous me parlez alors bien sûr je ne
parle pas de l'accompagnement qui avait
été voté aussi financier etc
la proposition de loi adoptée
effectivement par votre haute assemblée
en décembre vise en ce sens à faciliter
le développement des communes nouvelles
et améliorées surtout les périodes
transitoires notamment ceux qui
concernent la composition des conseils
municipaux d'hier la deuxième période
ce texte a été reçue très positivement
il a été soutenu par le gouvernement
il est aujourd'hui bien sûr nécessaire
de d'envisager sa lecture mais il est
envisagé bien sûr à la lumière des
concertations menées actuellement avec
les maires dans le cadre du grand débat
à ce stade il a donc été décidé de
différer son examen monsieur
le sénateur et il ne faut pas toujours
voir le mal quelque part ses pieds noirs
pour 39 secondes
madame la ministre on reproche souvent
au parlement sa lenteur dans la
confection de la loi mais aujourd'hui
c'est le gouvernement qui bloque selon
le gouvernement qui ne veut pas
comprendre qu'il ya urgence à légiférer
sur ce texte notamment à la proche des
futures élections municipales j'entends
bien à votre volonté affichée d'être à
l'écouté je m'en félicite
c'est un changement notable peut-être
pourriez-vous aller jusqu'à entendre la
volonté des parlementaires qui
travaillent et qu'ils se saisissent des
attentes des élus locaux en étroite
collaboration d'ailleurs avec
l'association des maires de france
pourriez peut-être pourriez-vous
collectivement dans votre gouvernement
consacré un peu moins de temps à
l'animation du show médiatique de votre
mentor et davantage à une meilleure
considération du travail des élus
nationaux peut-être pourriez-vous
peut-être pourriez-vous enfin tout
simplement respecter vos engagements par
rapport aux élus que nous sommes
[Applaudissements]
je vous rappelle que les prochaines
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
auront lieu mardi 12 mars à 16h45 et
seront retransmis sur public sénat le
site internet du sénat et sur facebook
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h15 pour la proposition de
loi relative à la nationalisation des
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroutes
et à l'affectation des dividendes à
l'agencé de financement des
infrastructures de transport de france
la séance est suspendue
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement il ya eu
beaucoup de questions sur les droits des
femmes à la veille du 8 mars la journée
internationale des droits des femmes et
la sénatrice les républicains céline
boulay espère rogner a dénoncé le
laxisme du gouvernement face au port du
voile islamique hidjab qui est selon
elle imposée à des milliers de femmes en
france la secrétaire d'état geneviève
darrieussecq a rappelé le principe de
laïcité de liberté de culte et le
respect de la volonté de chacun et puis
il ya eu un échange fort autour de
l'agression de deux surveillants
pénitentiaires à la prison de
condé-sur-sarthe la sénatrice centriste
de l'orne nathalie goulet a dénoncé
l'échec du gouvernement pour protéger
les surveillants pénitentiaires et la
ministre de la justice nicole belloubet
lui a répondu en rappelant que le budget
de la sécurité des prisons avait
augmenté cette année de 16% et que les
surveillants pénitentiaires à led équipé
d'équipements nouveaux notamment du
gilet par l'âme pour être mieux protégés
voilà jérôme pour les moments forts de
ces questions d'actualité du sénat au
gouvernement
merci beaucoup alexandre et on va tout
de suite prendre la direction de la
salle des conférences du sénat puisque
tam tran huy vous êtes avec la ministre
chargée des transports elisabeth bornes
et nous allons parler ensemble du projet
de loi mobilité le projet de loi à
l'homme madame board
et bien tout d'abord un certain nombre
de sénateurs sont inquiets sur ce projet
de loi pour il manque toujours 500
millions d'euros il pose toujours cette
même question du financement que leur
répondez-vous pour les rassurer
alors écoutez je pense qu'il faut pas
réduire ce projet de loi à ce débat ça
n'est pas une loi de finances et moi je
me réjouis que la commission et puis
adopté hier le texte
je pense de façon très large ce qui
montre que on a eu un travail de qualité
en amont avec les sénateurs avec
beaucoup d'amendements déposés sur ce
taxi 140 modifie pas effectivement les
grands équilibres ni les principales
dispositions du texte
donc moi je me réjouis de l'adhésion du
sénat à ses orientations et d'autant
plus que je pense que la crise que nous
traversons confirme que les français
attendent qu'on améliore leur
déplacement du quotidien qu on les
simplifie et c'est bien l'objet de ce
texte
donc ça confirme l'importance et
l'urgence de se taire est ce pour vous
une bonne solution de flécher la tei cpe
vers les infrastructures de transport
c'est là est bien l'une des propositions
qui est fait par le rapporteur du
diamant délire alors je vous confirme
que cette année il ya bien 1,2 milliard
de thijs cpe qui est affecté au
financement des infrastructures donc à
l' agence de financement des
infrastructures qui a adopté son budget
la semaine dernière un budget qui va
nous permettre de tenir les engagements
qui ont été pris par le gouvernement
ce sont des projets qui sont très
attendues ces améliorations des
transports du quotidien c'est essentiel
c'est plus important que jamais donc
jouera sur le budget et bien été adoptée
de la fille pour 2019 alors quid de la
vignette poids lourds on sait qu'il ya
eu des discussions à ce sujet on sait
que l'une des difficultés c'est que l'on
ne peut pas faire une vignette poids
lourd spécialement pour les poids lourds
venus de l'étranger
votre réflexion est encore en cours sur
ce sujet alors vous savez que on a
toujours indiqué que pour 2020 il
fallait réfléchir effectivement à une
nouvelle recette donc vous comprendrez
que c'est évidemment un sujet qui est
débattu dans le cadre du grand débat
moi je vais pas présenté les conclusions
du grand débat j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire je pense que et quand je me déplace
dans les territoires à l'occasion du
grand débat ou à d'autres occasions
je vois des français qui en effet voit
passer beaucoup de poids lourds
étrangers qui font le plein en belgique
en luxembourg et puis ensuite en espagne
et qui utilisent nos infrastructures
sans participer au financement
donc je continue à penser que c'est une
bonne piste de travail pour conclure
elisabeth dents de certains sénateurs
jugent que le texte n'est pas off à ses
offensives sur la question de l'ubs et
risation des transports je cite certains
sénateurs de gauche c'est une véritable
gangrène qui mine la cohésion de notre
pays il faut t'il mieux réguler et bien
cette libéralisation des transports
c'est bien l'objet du texte à la fois de
se dire qu'on a beaucoup de nouvelles
solutions que les plateformes numériques
peuvent apporter beaucoup de nouvelles
solutions mais que bien évidemment on
doit s'assurer que ça se fait pas au
détriment des travailleurs qui notamment
donc fournissent les services de ces
plateformes
il y avait une disposition dans le texte
qui visait justement à permettre la mise
en place de chartes dans ses plateformes
il aimait d'un amendement de suppression
mais on aura l'occasion d'en rediscuter
je ne doute pas
en séance et moi je me réjouis par
avance de du débat qu'on va pouvoir
avoir sur ce texte vient effectivement
merci beaucoup et isabelle banque
d'avoir répondu à mes questions alors
qu'on va avoir bien l'occasion de vous
revoir au sénat puisque effectivement
l'examen du texte commence dans quelques
jours en séance merci beaucoup et
également et bien à mes côtés il y à
aussi bien nicole belloubet nicole
belloubet la garde des sceaux qui a été
largement interrogé lors de cette séance
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
bien sûr après et bien les événements
les agressions de condé sur sarthe
les surveillants demandent une
revalorisation sécuritaire indemnitaire
statutaire allez vous pouvoir répondre à
ses revendications
alors d'abord je voudrais dire que la
préoccupation de la sécurité dans les
établissements pénitentiaires est une
préoccupation très forte de ce
gouvernement
nous avons pris depuis l'année dernière
un nombre important de mesures
je le rappelais à madame la sénatrice
goulet qui m'a interrogé sur ce sujet
nous avons pris des mesures en matière
de traitement des détenus qui sont
radicalisées des mesures en matière de
sécurité des établissements
pénitentiaires et des mesures également
en faveur de la sécurité des personnels
une nouvelle mesure a pour l'instant en
cours autant manifestement ces
événements montrent qu'il y à une
défaillance soit dans nos
réglementations soient dans la mise en
oeuvre général de ces réglementations
comme vous le savez j'ai
demandé à l'inspection générale de la
justice de se rendre dans
l'établissement pour mesurer la manière
dont les choses s'étaient déroulées
parce qu'en effet c'est paradoxal qu'une
telle situation se soit déroulé à
condé-sur-sarthe celles établies
simplement aussi c'est celle qu'elle
n'était pas en surpopulation car voilà
exactement c'est un aux deux
établissements les plus sécuritaires et
n'avons pas de surpopulation donc ne
s'est pas seulement une question de
moyens donc nous devons voir ce qui
s'est passé et en tirer les règles
générales lors de l'examen du projet de
loi justice le rapporteur françois noël
buffet avait proposé de renforcer les
fouille des visiteurs dans les prisons à
l'époque où vous y étiez opposé
alors quelle raison est ce que vous avez
changé d'avis quand vous ne voyez ce qui
s'est passé là s'ils voulaient d'abord
dont la loi de réforme de la justice
nous avons modifié un article sur les
fouilles des détenus qui correspondait
également à une demande forte des
syndicats des personnels pénitentiaires
et nous a semblé que c'était de bon sens
donc nous avons modifié cela pour
permettre tout en restant conforme à la
réglementation nous européennes et
nationales nous avons accru ses
possibilités de fouilles sur la fouille
des visiteurs
si je n'avais pas accédé à cette demande
c'est parce qu'il me semblait que il
n'était pas interdit par notre propre
réglementation de procéder à de telles
fouilles donc il faut vérifier cela et
il faut mesurer la pratique également
fort et pensions peut-être à ce sujet
que l'on voit que absolue c'est un peu
une visiteuse ce sera les conclusions du
rapport d'inspection de chez demander
toute dernière question à ce que vous
jugez qu'aujourd'hui nos prisons sont
aptes à incarcérer des revenants des
terroristes revenus d'irak ou de syrie
on voyait tout ce débat sur la
radicalisation de ces difficultés et
bien mais juguler ce la danse mais il
n'y a pas de doute là dessus
nous sommes parfaitement en mesure de
pouvoir accueillir dans nos
établissements pénitentiaires des
personnes dont la dangerosité est avérée
quelle qu'en soit la raison mais y
compris des personnes qui sont soit des
détenus terroristes soient des personnes
radicaliser nous sommes parfaitement
dans capacité de les prendre en charge
nous en avons déjà accueilli soit des
personnes qui sont radicalisés en france
et qui sont restés ici soit des
personnes qui sont parties en syrie ou
ailleurs et qui sont revenus en france
il y en a déjà quelques-uns dans nos
établissements pénitentiaires donc
évidemment nous les accueillons ce qui
ne veut pas dire si c'est la question
sous jacente que la france a changé de
position je le redis ici nous
n'accueillons pas de nouvelles personnes
revenues des terrains de combat bien
merci beaucoup une cale belloubet
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup au tas mais on va revenir
pendant vingt minutes encore sur cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et pour ce faire
j'accueille sur le plateau emmanuel
capus bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
sénateur du maine et loire membre du
groupe indépendant république et
territoires et on l'a vu cette séance de
questions d'actualité
elle a été marquée par la thématique des
droits des femmes à la veille de la
journée internationale du droit des
femmes vous êtes notamment
vice-président de la délégation
sénatoriale aux entreprises on l'a
entendu il ya des indicateurs qui ont
été créés dans les entreprises est-ce
que ça suffit pour finalement renforcer
l'égalité femmes hommes
alors je suis vice-président de la
délégation aux entreprises je suis aussi
avocat dans la vie et ma vraie qualité
principale c'est droit du travail
justement je pense qu'il y a
effectivement beaucoup de mesures qui
ont déjà été pris avec les accords
d'entreprise sur l'égalité hommes femmes
qui ont été prises par le passé
aujourd'hui on a un index supplémentaire
qui est pris il ya un principe général
du droit qui est très général et qui
parle de l'égalité de traitement
mais de façon générale pas seulement
entre les hommes et les femmes mais ça
s'applique évidemment aussi entre les
hommes et les femmes à partir du moment
où c'est un travail égal salaire égal
donc les outils juridiques je pense
qu'ils existent déjà je pense que ce
qu'il faut changer ils sont bons ce
qu'il faut changer c'est la mentalité
l'index va permettre effectivement de
savoir pour certaines femmes si elles
sont seulement dans les grandes barres
alors oui dans les grands groupes mais
après c'est pour ça que je pense que les
choses changeront quand on changera les
mentalités ça c'est pour l'égalité
salariés
elle est extrêmement importante
puisqu'on c'est qu'effectivement on a
d'abord les femmes sont majoritaires à
travailler en france 52 % des
travailleurs sont des femmes et elles
sont payées 9% de moins que les hommes
en général
moi je pense qu'effectivement il faut
continuer à changer les mentalités pour
que notamment dans les petites
entreprises
on considère totalement anormal qu'une
femme soit moins payés qu'à nommer ya
pas que ça parce que l'égalité hommes
femmes ça ne passe pas que par l'égalité
salariale
ça passe également énormément par les
promotions sociales la ministre a dit
d'ailleurs c'était bien les promotions
sociales et promotion de carrière de
carrière les évolutions de carrière et
puis l'émotion en politique que si la
famille est alors à beaucoup de postes
de pouvoir
les femmes je pense que c'est en train
de changer ça prend du temps nous dans
notre bourg coupe effectivement on n'a
pas beaucoup de femmes on se faisait la
réflexion en séance et on aimerait en
avoir plus
le mode les modes de scrutins font qu'
on va avoir beaucoup plus de femmes
puisque dans tous les scrutins de liste
maintenant et à la parité
donc petit à petit les choses vont se
faire moi je viens d'un milieu où je
travaille quasiment qu'avec des femmes
puisque je fais dans le monde de la
justice
chez ça c'est fait depuis longtemps et
naturellement dans le montage il ya
beaucoup de femmes donc ce n'est pas une
cause désespérée
les femmes ont toute leur place et
prennent de plus en plus de place et je
veux dire et dans le monde politique je
pense qu'elles vont de prendre et je
voulais terminer par le fait qu' il faut
et aussi dans le monde salarial qu'on
aide énormément les femmes à gérer les
absences pour pour les la natalité pour
les congés maternité parce que souvent à
la carrière souvent c'est aussi encore
maintenant et c'est dramatique
un handicap dans la promotion de
carrière et ça c'est totalement anormal
alors justement sur ce sujet il ya une
question séance et c'est agnès buzyn la
ministre de la santé qui a répondu sur
le cas particulier de la hausse des
féminicides en france on l'écoutent
concrètes ont déjà été prises
j'en citerai quelques unes et vous savez
les moyens financiers sont conséquents
puisque 3 530 millions d'euros ont été
inscrits au plf 2010 9
donc c'est un budget
important je crois le plus important
jamais dédiée à cette cause de l'égalité
entre les femmes et des hommes mais vous
m'interrogez sur les violences faites
aux femmes sur les féminicides nous
sommes engagés très rapidement sur la
création de centres de prise en charge
du psycho traumatismes notamment dédié
aux femmes victimes de violences
sexuelles
effectivement victime de violence tout
court de leur conjoint nous avons fait
un appel à projet n'a pas la candidature
l'année dernière ces dix centres ont été
créés labellisés nous sommes le premier
pays au monde à organiser des réseaux de
prise en charge des victimes de psycho
traumatisme wendel capi on né le 7 mars
et a déjà eu trente femmes qui sont
mortes sous leurs sous les coups de leur
compagnon ou ex-compagnon depuis le
début de l'année en france
c'est une situation inacceptable cette
situation inacceptable et ce d'autant
plus que effectivement dans la question
nous a dit qu'il avait pas plus de
réponse pénale
ces faits d'homicides de féminicide donc
c'est inacceptable j'espère que la prime
que le gouvernement a pris en compte ces
augmentations et le les centres de prise
en charge des victimes
ça me parait tu es un outil extrêmement
utile et intéressant pour essayer de
sortir les femmes qui sont menacés de ce
contexte familial la réponse des gens si
ceux ci on a entendu la dernière victime
elle avait donné des signes d' alerte
avait prévenu la police et pourtant rien
n'a été fait moi je pense de façon plus
globale que le budget de la justice
souhaite un budget c'est ce que je
défends la commission des finances qui
doit être sanctuarisé même augmenté
parce que c'est c'est ça le vrai pouvoir
régalien de l'état
et c'est là dessus qu'on doit mettre le
paquet merci emmanuel capus sur un tout
autre sujet ans va rejoindre tam tran
huy qui est avec le ministre de
l'agriculture didier guillaume wii est
la veille du bilan on va commencer par
une question sur la place des femmes
dans l'agriculture on sait que la place
est parfois compliqué qu est ce que vous
avez fait pour les femmes dans
l'agriculture au niveau de l'exécutif
face ces dernières années à la veille du
8 mars du wydad il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup d'efforts ont été faits
au niveau des femmes en général mais
dans l'agriculture également dans la
mesure où il ya beaucoup de femmes
agricultrices chef d'exploitation
donc nous avons mis en place des droits
nouveaux notamment pour les congés de
maternité notamment pour le remplacement
il est indispensable qu'une femme
agricultrice du brain ses congés de
maternité qu'elle puisse être remplacée
pour son travail et nous avons sont
beaucoup avec marlène schiappa dont
l'enfant une visite sur des
exploitations tenue exclusivement par
des femmes puisqu'elles sont nombreuses
et motivez votre bilan sinon du salon de
l'agriculture alors que le monde
agricole fait bien depuis plusieurs
années face à la ghriba chine sur la
question des pesticides les fermes
usines de bien-être animal
il ya bien des sujets sur lesquels le
monde agricole doit se défendre
aujourd'hui oui le bilan du champ de la
culture est un bilan très positif ça a
été un salon totalement tourné vers les
françaises et des français
nous avons montré ce qui t'est
l'agriculture française une culture
d'excellence une alimentation sur scène
et durable et le visage qui a montré
d'agriculture françaises qui ont montré
toutes les filières a été formidable en
effet la culture est en train de muter
la culture se transforme la culture va
vers l'agroécologie cette transition est
indispensable et c'est comme cela que
les françaises et des français je crois
non perçues c'était un très bon salon un
salon très positif vous mettez l'accent
sur l'agroécologie est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui lors du déplacement des
manuels macro à gréoux-les-bains sur le
thème de l'environnement
énormément de questions qui ont concerné
l'agriculture sur le loup le bio la loi
foncière
vous ne regrettez pas de ne pas y être
allé pour pouvoir répondre à ce type de
questions avant mais d'abord chez le
président de la république qui répond
c'est pas les mini géants voit quand
tout cas l'environnement
[Musique]
tour de rôle oui l'agriculture est très
présente l'agriculture et la ruralité
sont les fondements même de notre
société
fair nation faire france sait tenir
compte de cette ruralité et de cette
agriculture et donc les questions je
vous dis poser au président de la
république sur le bio sur la transition
agro écologiques sur le prédateur sont
des questions qui traversent toute
l'agriculture et j'ai j'ai entendu ce
qu'a répondu le président de la
république évidemment je suis totalement
dans cette dans cette ligne là c'est par
la transition agro écologique que nous y
arriverons
c'est par une nouvelle façon
d'appréhender la culture et en même
temps c'est en soutenant les
agriculteurs en soutenant les éleveurs
de nos montées sèches comme dans les
alpes-de-haute-provence face aux
prédateurs face au loup il dit guillaume
pour conclure eh bien ce sont de
l'agriculture a bien sûr été marquée
comme chaque année par l'avis du
président de la république emmanuel
macron sa visite s'est bien passé ça a
été plutôt à une promenade de santé
alors qu'on pouvait attendre les gilet
jaune et il y as sur les réseaux sociaux
des accusations à l'égard de la
république en marche qui jugent qu'elle
que la république en mars a mobilisé 200
militants pour soutenir le président de
la république qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez et d'assurer cas je réponds pas
aux réseaux sociaux parce que y'a
tellement d'absurdité sur les réseaux
sociaux tous les jours il n'y a pas que
des actualités mais comment faire mettre
des militants enfin c'est là s'était
ouvert au public et beaucoup de monde
il a eu des discussions avec avec tous
les gens qui étaient là qu'est ce que ça
veut dire c'est en aidant une société
complotistes on est dans une société
comme on dit en patois drômois de fake
news je crois qu'il faut reprendre la
réalité ce qui a peut-être ennui est
certain c'est que le président de la
république a répondu aux questions que
se posait le monde agricole les
agriculteurs c'est qu'il a fait un
discours de plus d'une heure qui était
très apprécié par tous les syndicats
agricoles qu'il a pris la mesure de ce
kit est l'agriculture française la
souveraineté alimentaire de ce que
devait être l'agriculture dans l'europe
et je pense que c'est pour ça que là la
visite s'est bien passée c'était pas
uniquement une promenade de santé parce
que quand on prend dans plus de 14
heures
c'est une voix un vrai exercice un vrai
marathon de santé marathon de santé
merci beaucoup d'idées guillaume d'abord
répondu à mes questions
merci tam et autres thèmes abordés lors
de cette séance de questions d'actualité
au gouvernement la politique
industrielle de la france et c'est agnès
pannier relâché secrétaire d'état à
l'économie qui a répondu sur cette
question on écoute depuis 20 ans
l'emploi industriel a diminué de 1
million un million et depuis deux ans il
progresse et pourquoi parce que nous
avons mis en place une politique
industrielle ambitieuse
premièrement une politique à 12 une
politique industrielle qui permet le
développement de l'activité économique
en rendant la plateforme françaises plus
compétitives
c'est ça qui explique que toyota
investit 300 millions d'euros en france
daimler 500 millions d'euros en france
et que nous sommes désormais la première
destination des investissements directs
à l'étranger pour l'industrie emmanuel
capus on a entendu la ministre
la france crée des emplois industriels
et pourtant on entend parler de ford
d'ascq ovale il ya une question aussi
sur un groupe allemand dans le domaine
sucrier qui fermait comme ça de manière
unilatérale
est ce qu'il ya une politique
industrielle volontariste du
gouvernement
moi je pense que sur cette question là
je crois pas qu'on puisse dire que ce
gouvernement est pas sensible à la
politique industrielle et à l'industrie
dont moi je serai tendance j'aurais
tendance à penser que la réponse daniel
spagnou est assez forte et moi me
satisfait pour que moi en train de ces
grands groupes étrangers de fermer comme
ford par exemple il ya deux choses en
fait il ya le verre à moitié plein et le
moyeu le verre à moitié vide
agnès pannier c'est son rôle l axe sur
le verre à moitié plein elle explique ce
qui va bien et c'est quand même une ex
une décisif à une assez bonne
le fait qu'on ait plus d'emplois dans
l'industrie depuis deux ans donc ça je
ne faut pas faire de politique
politicienne faut s'en féliciter
en revanche évidemment ça n'écarte pas
le fait qu'il ya des déceptions et des
échecs
jérôme bignon a rappelé celui de soudou
coeur qui veut fermer trois sites en
france dans l'industrie sucrière et
betteravière ça c'est pas acceptable
le rôle de l'état à ce niveau là et ça a
été très clairement dit par didier
guillaume c'est de faire pression sur le
groupe qui plus est un groupe allemand
pour que ça ne ferme pas ou qu'on trouve
une solution européenne sur la filière
sucrière et puis à la question
blanquefort une forme on à l usine ford
qui ferme maintenant le rôle de l'état
faut pas se mentir il ya des solutions
qui nous qui sont proposés par madame
marie ben ma collègue socialiste qui dit
il faudrait qu'ils aient une prise de
participation temporaire de l'état ça ne
marche pas on l'a essayé par le passé
c'est absolument pas le rôle de l'état
de racheter une usine qui est qu'étant
aquifère moyens face et c'est grenoble
américain elle propose effectivement
éventuellement de s'appuyer davantage
sur les régions je suis tout à fait
favorable
elle propose de créer des grandes
coopératives européennes de type airbus
j'y suis tout à fait favorable ce qu'il
faut de façon plus globale c'est
effectivement avoir une politique
industrielle forte et avoir une
politique de compétitivité des
entreprises qui soit forte
ça veut dire un coût du travail moins
élevé ça veut dire une fiscalité des
entreprises moins élevé pour que les
entreprises n'est pas un intérêt se
délocaliser alors pour le coût du
travail moins élevés ces entreprises
elles ont touché des aides quand elles
ferment comme ça des sites industriels
faut qu'elle ait remboursé z
je serai pas tête ce serait pas
totalement illogique effectivement si
elles ont touché des années qu'elle
parte il serait normal qu'elles
remboursent leurs danois et concrètement
comment on fait pour encourager encore
davantage la création
on a entendu un nombre d'emplois non
pourvus dans l'industrie faut travailler
sur quoi sur la formation et sur
l'apprentissage un gros travail sur la
formation il ya énormément moi dans ma
région
on a énormément où on a un taux de
chômage assez faibles plus faible que la
moyenne nationale
on a énormément d'emplois que l'on ne
réussit pas à pourvoir
donc il faut travailler sur la formation
vous travaillez sur l'accès à des
emplois dans l'industrie faudra y faire
la mobilité aussi parce qu'il ya des
endroits en france où il ya des gens qui
ont pas de travail et d'autres où on
cherche des travailleurs il faut
travailler sur sur la sur la
compétitivité des entreprises
autre sujet un peu lié tout de même
l'europe ça y est la campagne des
élections européennes est lancée les
républicains ont publié leurs listes
hier en marche on a vu emmanuel macron
il est écrit une lettre aux européens
pour une renaissance de l'europe
vous êtes délégué national d'agir vous
soutenez la république en marché aux
élections européennes nous on a pris une
position qui est très claire
hier agir soutiendra une liste de
rassemblement avec en marche avec les
radicaux avec tout ce qu'ils veulent
avec les amis d'alain juppé et d'options
pierre raffarin tous ceux qui veulent
effectivement faire progresser l'europe
suivre le programme le projet qui a été
envoyé à tous les citoyens européens par
emmanuel macron lundi plus de liberté
plus de progrès plus de construction
collective de l'europe oui effectivement
agir après position très claire et moi
je soutiendrai la liste de rater la
république en marche
je vous remercie emmanuel capus d'avoir
été mon invité pour revenir sur cette
triche séance de questions d'actualité
au gouvernement et on retourne voir ta
mme tran huy en salle des conférences du
sénat puisque tam vous êtes avec jean
françois longeot sénateur union
centriste du doubs et oui et avec jean
françois longeot nous allons parler
ensemble delà du projet de loi
l'homme qui va arriver d'ici quelques
jours au sénat outre le problème du
financement vous jugez vous que ce
projet de loi ne vient pas suffisamment
répondre aux problèmes de la ruralité
pourquoi oui effectivement c'est vrai
que nous en sommes aperçus ce projet de
loi correspond à une réalité sur de
manioc bain mais sur la ruralité il
manque beaucoup de choses et
effectivement c'est pour ça que moi j'ai
proposé je vais déposer un amendement
notamment en matière de transports parce
que c'est vrai que nous n'avons pas dans
les secteurs ruraux tous les équipements
transport que ce soit le tram le métro
est haute et donc pour les personnels
qui veulent aller travailler et qui
habitent dans des petites villes et qui
veulent travailler dans des endroits un
peu éloigné je crois que il est
important que nous puissions apporter
notre contribution et cette loi
permettre effectivement par exemple
d'utiliser le mode de transport scolaire
pour effectivement les salariés pour que
chacune et chacun puisse se déplacer
correctement et se rendre au travail ce
qui plaît est-ce que c'est paradoxal que
ce projet de loi ne soit pas
suffisamment présents sur ce thème là
alors même que ce sont les thèmes qui
est soit à l'origine du mouvement de
gilet jaune sept problèmes d de
désenclavement qu'il fouille s'est
accélérée à auxonne
mais c'est vrai que ça peut paraître dès
fois compliqué hein effectivement de
modifier
ah les modes de transport dans le monde
rural parce qu'aujourd'hui endroit là
par la voiture
vous n'avez pas d'autres modes de
transport il ya beaucoup de volets sur
le vélo sur choses comme ça dans cette
loi mais nous c'est pas c'est pas un
outil facile à utiliser pour se rendre
au travail ou d'ailleurs pour avoir
diverses activités que ce soit des
activités associatives ou sportive et
donc il est important que nous puissions
faire des propositions et nous puissions
effectivement faire entendre non pas
d'une façon efforts des autres mais de
faire entendre la voix du secteur rural
bien merci beaucoup jean françois
longeot d'avoir hébergé à mes questions
verse alors que ce projet de loi nome va
être examiné dans quelques jours au
sénat merci beaucoup
tam et avant de se quitter un dernier
détour par l'hémicycle pour retrouver
alexandre pousse à alexandre il y a
actuellement une proposition de loi des
propositions de loi communiste et une
notamment sur l'interdiction des
lanceurs de balles de défense les ailes
bd et où germé sur cette question des
ailes bd il va y avoir un affrontement
politique entre d'un côté la gauche du
sénat qui est pour l'interdiction de ces
lanceurs de balles de défense et de
l'autre côté la majorité sénatoriale qui
estime que cette interdiction
fragiliserait l'action des forces de
l'ordre face aux manifestants violents
alors concrètement un ce texte des
sénateurs communistes demandent
l'interdiction immédiate de l' usage de
ses armes non létales par les forces de
l'ordre
les sénateurs communistes demandent
aussi plus de transparence il souhaite
car à chaque lendemain de manifestations
les chiffres sur l' usage de ces armes
par les policiers soient rendus publics
alors la commission des lois du sénat a
rejeté cette proposition d'interdiction
la majorité du sénat est contre car elle
estime que ces lbd permettent une
réponse graduée des forces de l'ordre à
ces manifestants violents il est donc
peu probable que clb dès ce soir soit
interdite par les sénateurs merci
beaucoup alexandre poussard et c'est
déjà la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi à 18h30 vous
retrouver l'émission on va plus loin
excellente suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]